it's usually a learning experience when
Sofia Alvarado takes his children to the
turtle ponds the family belongs to the
key to our people who have lived in a
you suni National Park for generations
the park is also home to the hungry
river turtles but it'll be getting
crowded for humans and animals alike
Ecuador's government plans to drill for
oil here in the philosophy of the
kitchens progress means having a good
life we should maintain the resources at
our disposal we can protect nature over
the long term so that our community will
also have a good life in the future el
buen beard a las comunidades but the
good life of the key to us is under
threat at the same time every day in the
afternoon when its hottest the whole
family takes a break in the shade of a
house then everyone gets chicha
it's a beverage made from the fruits or
roots of various indigenous plants like
yuca Cepheus wife unit prepares the
traditional drink over an open fire but
lately she doesn't know where to get
good quality yuca from a lot of yuca and
banana plants are dying off I planted
new ones but they died too so I got
fruit from the village market and it
made the children sick I think
everything's been contaminated here we
ask Sergio to show us the source of the
contamination we only have to travel a
short distance on the rio napo the
biggest river in yes any National Park
and so that the children learn something
they all come along too we soon arrived
at the first gas flare one of the many
in the area that are always burning less
than a kilometre away we meet a group of
workers who are using barriers and hoses
to clean the banks of leaked oil
the Yasuni rainforest is one of the
world's most important bastions in the
fight against climate change nowhere is
there a greater variety of flora and
fauna species but the wealth in the
region that interests Ecuador's
government isn't crude form underground
or was at least until 45 years ago when
the state started extracting the oil
since then much of the Nature Preserve
has changed only a few areas remain
untouched so in 2007 acquittals
president proposed not drilling in the
area if the international community paid
him half the value of the oil that would
have been extracted the area is known as
the ITT block that the president wanted
to protect in exchange for hard cash
it contains 20% of Ecuador's oil
reserves but it only accounts for a
small area in the eastern part of the
biosphere reserve despite international
support the initiative generated just a
small fraction of the expected funds so
the president reversed his plan and gave
the go-ahead to start drilling in the
parks at ITT block
Lamine don't mean unfortunately we have
to say that the world has failed us yeah
the world isn't willing to help save one
of the planets last green lungs and the
president needs money to pay off state
debt now environmental activists take to
the streets to demand the nature
preservation
necesita SRO Jetson our country needs
development and growth and we have to
use our resources but these resources
shouldn't come from exploiting and
destroying one of the earth's most
valuable green lungs the oil in question
would earn Ecuador profits of around 7
billion euros burning it would produce
some 400 million tons of co2 and the
world would need just nine days to
consume the oil this doesn't just affect
the people living in the region but the
people of the whole world that's why we
turn to the rich countries that they're
the biggest responsibility for climate
change the oil production will cause
many problems like deforestation of the
Amazon region or the contamination of
the water under the entire park in a
Sierra you know the rest of the place we
travel deep into the Yasuni rainforest
to meet the people who'd be most
affected by the drilling the Huaorani
indigenous group word up to the
president we couldn't have gone now
he doesn't want to see journalists in
Yasuni especially now we were forced to
smuggle our camera equipment past
military checkpoints in order to see for
ourselves weather will Ronnie live some
have never had contact with civilization
they live a two-hour drive and an
additional 3 to 4 hour boat ride from
the nearest city on one of their rare
journeys away from home Martin and
gababa hora
he was the village elder heard about
plans that would bring pipelines and
drilling rigs deeper into the forest I
don't want these people to come here
they'll change our lives we live here
our way and everything we have comes
from nature
it's a very healthy life
the were running welcome an usual
afternoon rain shower at this time of
year it's a relief from the heat after
it rains the people get back to work
gaba and martin are preparing curare
arrows for hunting
curare is a plant based poison that
paralyzes the respiratory systems of
monkeys and parrots this land belongs to
everyone we need it to live we don't
want them to drill oil here why should
we change our lives or language for them
we just want to continue living here
while two were ronny head out to hunt
for monkeys and parrots the state-run
oil company Petrobras ona's prepares to
conquer this unique forest three other
indigenous peoples have already fled the
oil rigs Gabbar and his family could be
the next in search of new hunting
grounds